what we're celebrating now is Fasnacht
than you know that goes back to the days
of the Druids
and it is the first holiday that the
Swiss settlers remembered or celebrated
when they came here they came in 18 and
it's always the I believe for the first
weekend before Lent
it starts in the Nouveau so it's all the
fees to eat fatty foods people they
dance say have a good time you have the
Old Man Winter scarecrow and you dance
till midnight and everyone sort of
masquerade ball you try to put on scary
or interesting mascara literally
people come it's always fun watching
integers checking it out looking at all
the masks
I think pause locked is fairly important
to the economic success of the talents
it most of it just for us and we just
have a quail of a good time